[Müzik]
Merhabalar ben Özkan Öztürk Spor
spikeriyim Futbol güzel bir oyun bu
güzel oyun bana Büyülü Bir Yol açtı ve
Açıkçası bu yolculuğu Bugün sizlerle
paylaşmak istiyorum
Tabii sokakta oyun oynayarak yetişen bir
neslin şanslı temsilcisi olarak açıkçası
Bugün buradayım Benim Hayatım futboldu
tutkulu bir şekilde futbolu yaşıyordum
çok seviyordum deliler gibi futbol
maçları izliyor sokakta sadece futbol
oynuyordum ve oynarken bir yandan da
anlatıyordum attığım golleri yaptığım
asistleri hep anlatırdım oyunun içinde
Bende farklı bir oyun oynuyordum
işte sonrasında büyüdük lise bitti
ÖSS'ye girdim çok çalışkan bir öğrenci
olamadım hiçbir zaman Barajı geçtim bir
şekilde aldığım puanlarla Anadolu'da
birkaç bölüme girebiliyordum ama bana
göre değildi Kendimi orada göremiyordum
İstanbulda kalmak istiyordum radyo
televizyon istiyordum Çünkü futbolun
içinde bu sektörde olma Hedefim vardı
Bir gün gazetede bir ilan gördüm tam
sayfa yeni açılan bir Meslek Yüksekokulu
tabi ilk öğrencilerini arıyor Bundan
dolayı
ekonomik anlamda da uygun Babama
söyledim sonrasında birlikte gittik
kafamıza yattı görüştük orada bir
hanımefendi vardı dedi Siz radyo
televizyon Bence yapamazsınız bence
uygun değilsiniz sizi Biz uluslararası
ilişkilere yazalım dedi ilk tercih
olarak sonrasında Babam da kendisini
onayladı aynı şekilde Çünkü ben çok
İçime kapanık bir insandım çok çirkin
geldim Dışarıdan da bu çok fazla belli
oluyordu özgüvensiz baktığınızda
giyimiyle kuşamıyla her yönüyle
afiştim Yani net bir şekilde Belli
oluyordu bu
Öyle de oldu ilk iki tercih onların
istediği gibi oldu birinci öğretim ve
ikinci öğretim olarak uluslararası
ilişkiler yazdılar üçüncü dördüncü
tercih Benim istediğimdi 3 tercih işte
birinci Öğretim 4 tercih radyo Tv ikinci
öğretim Ben de ikinci öğretim istiyorum
çünkü diyorum ki kendi kendime gündüz
çalışırım bir şekilde sektöre girerim
akşamları da okula giderim Neyse bir ay
kadar Bir süre sonra tercihler açıklandı
Ve tabii ki benim istediğim oldu bu bir
kırılma anıydı Yani birinci ikinci
üçüncü tercih olmadı 4 tercih çıktı ben
okula başladım 6 aylık bir süre geçmişti
Ama ben her gün hocalarımla paylaşıyorum
ben spor spikeri olmak istiyorum maç
spikeri olmak istiyorum Benim futbolda
olmam lazım bu sektörde olmam lazım diye
hep kendimi gösteriyorum belli ediyorum
derslerde Çünkü çoğu kişi daha tam karar
verememişti ne olmak istediğini tam
olarak değerlendirememişti Kafasında bir
gün bir hocamız geldi Özkan dedi bir
radyo var dedi
habere muhabir arıyorlar dedi stajyer
Ben seni söyleyeceğim dedi Dedim hocam
yani ben futbol aşığıyım futbol
istiyorum spor varsa gideyim yoksa
başkasını söyleyeyim oğlum dedi Sen
kapıdan gir kendini atarsın sonrasında
spora dedi bana Nitekim ilerleyen
dönemde böyle de oldu
başladım yani radyoya gittim görüşeceğim
9 Şubat 2005 olağanüstü bir kar yağışı
İstanbul'da inanılmaz bir kış Her taraf
bembeyaz ulaşım iptal İstanbul iptal
İETT otobüsleri çalışmıyor özel halk
otobüsleri tek tük böyle yakalarsan
şanslısın Neyse ben yakaladım Taksim'e
gittim oradan metro 4 Levent Sanayi
Mahallesi Radyo Sanayi mahallesi'ndeydi
haber müdürünün yanına gittim dedi
sizden 2 kişi olacaktı dedi birinci
öğretimden bir kişi ikinci öğretimden
bir kişi diğer arkadaş beni aradı
kendisi hava muhalefeti sebebiyle
gelemeyeceğini söyledi Sen bu şartlarda
buraya geldin bu bana yeter dedi Başka
bir sorum yok sana dedi seni mülakata
almayacağım benim için bu yeterli senin
tutkunu görebiliyorum dedi ben
sonrasında
başladım staja bir aylık bir deneme
dönemi vardı yaklaşık bir ay Eğer
beğenilirsem 150 TL stajyer maaşıyla
radyoda devam edecektim Neyse ben o
sırada röportajlar yaptım beni her gün
Sokak röportajlarına gönderiyorlardı bir
konu tespit edip belirleyip beni Sokak
röportajlarına gönderiyorlardı Tabii ben
çok çekingen adres bile olmayan
ürkek bir insandım içime kapanıktım
Hatta minibüsten inerken yani müsait bir
yerde durabilirmişsiniz onu bile
diyemiyordum yani hani birinin inmesini
bekliyordum aradan bende ineyim
sıyrılayım diye o kadar yani Ama işte
Radyo bana çok şey kattı sadece mesleki
anlamda değil kişisel gelişim olarak da
bana çok şey öğretti çok şey kattı o
röportajlarda ilk etapta hep ben
dükkanlara girerdim daha steril ortam
kapalı rahatlıkla röportaj
yapabiliyordum sonra alıştıkça sokaktan
da insan çevirmeye başladım ses kayıt
cihazıyla röportajlar yapmaya başladım
Tabii 2 yıl bu şekilde geçti Çok özel
işler yaptın Okul 2 yıllıktı Çünkü Okul
bitince stajda otomatikman sona eriyor
işte Rauf Denktaş gelmişti mesela beni
bir haberden dolayı oraya göndermişlerdi
sadece ses kayıt cihazıyla onun
konuşmasını ben kaydedecektim ama orada
ben kendisiyle bir de özel röportaj
ayarlamıştım insiyatif
ve röportaj yapmıştım Örneğin yine
İstiklal Caddesi'nde Sokak röportajına
çıkmıştım Galatasaray Lisesi çıkışı
rahmetli Başkan Özhan canaydın'ı
yakalamıştım hemen Galatasaray'ın
gündemi ile futbol gündemiyle ilgili
sorular sormuştum ki spora da geçmeye
çalışıyorum ya hep kendime bir şeyler
bir yol bulmaya çalışıyorum haber
müdürümden de takdir almıştım 2 yıl
bitince Tabii ucuz işçi futbolla sektöre
Aşık beni kadroya da aldılar başarılı da
gidiyorum ama artık yeni bir şeyler
yapmam gerekiyordu bir şeyler üretmem
gerekiyordu farklı bir şey yapmam
lazımdı ve ben özel röportajlara
başladım ses kayıt cihazıyla sokakta
değil de stüdyoda işte telefon
röportajları o dönem yine lejyoner
futbolcularımız vardı Nihat Kahveci gibi
Tuncay Şanlı gibi Tugay Kerimoğlu gibi
Gökdeniz Karadeniz gibi o dönemin önemli
isimleri ile bir şekilde hep röportajlar
ayarladım bir kişiye ulaşabilmek için
8-9 farklı telefon görüşmesi yapıp 10
numaraya ulaşabiliyordum ama acayip bir
haz yani o ulaştığınızda röportaja ikna
ettiğinizde yani bilenler bilir
Çocuğunuz olmuş gibi seviniyorsunuz öyle
bir has ardından bu röportajları kısa
kısa bölümler halinde radyoda
programlarda yayınlıyordum röportajlar
tuttu bazı gazetelerde yer aldı Bazı
internet sitelerinde yer aldı işte
Özkan Öztürk'e konuşan x Özkan Öztürk'e
konuşan y şeklinde olağanüstü bir duygu
küçükken çocukken hayal ettiğim şeylere
yavaş yavaş ulaşıyorum ve bunu Radyo
yönetimi de gördü bu kez bana program
verdiler hafta içi her gün 15 dakika ve
ben o röportajları artık kendi
programımda yayınlıyordum yani
olağanüstü bir haz kendi programımda
yayınlamaya başladım bunun da devamı
geliyordu çok güzel anılar da yaşadı
Mesela Mehmet Okur NBA'de oynuyordu
Oscar karmasına seçildi Tarihte ilk kez
bir Türk maçında yer alacaktı All Star
karmasında izleyecektik ve benim o
röportajı yapmam gerekiyordu Mehmet
okur'a ulaşmam lazımdı bir şekilde yine
Telefonla ulaştım mesajlaştık şöyle bir
cevap dedi Çok yoğunuz arka arkaya
maçlar oynuyoruz uzun seyahatlerimiz var
nba'i takip edenler bilir o uzun uçak
yolculukları dedi iki gün içinde ben
sana döneceğim ama sana döndüğümde bu
röportajı hemen yapmamız lazım çok
zamanım yok dedi Ben de tabii ki hemen
seve seve Tamam dedim ama şimdi eve
gitsem Düşünsenize saat farkı da var
Amerika ile Ben hazırım dedi Nerede
Nasıl yapacağım benim bir şekilde
radyoda bulunmam lazım 2 gün radyoda
kaldım eve gitmedim başka çarem yok 2
gün büyük Emek harcadım o röportaj için
sadece bir örnek hepsini Emek
harcıyorduk ama işte bu tutku İçinizde
beslediğiniz Bu heyecan Tutku mesleği
olan aşkınız bunları size yaptırıyor ve
hiç de yorulmuyorsunuz iki gün boyunca
dedim o mesaj geldi Mehmet okurlar
röportaj yaptım ve büyük ses getirdi
Çünkü televizyon kanalları kendisine
ulaşmamışken ulaşamamışken Ben radyoda
mesleğe yeni yeni başlamış kendisini
ispat etmeye çalışan biri olarak o
röportajı yapmıştım bir yandan da tabii
maç anlatımlarından da geri kalmak
istemiyorum maç anlatımlarına da devam
etmek istiyorum çünkü en büyük tutkum bu
Sonrasında hep kafamda da bir Avrupa
hayali vardı çocukken ben o maçları
böyle izlerken televizyon başında Acaba
bir gün o statlara gidebilecek miyim O
şehirlere o ülkelere gidebilecek miyim
oralarda maç izleyebilecek miyim bunun
hayalini kuruyordum bunun hayaliyle
yaşıyordum
2010 Ben 8 ay kadar İspanyolca kursuna
gittim sonrasında kendimi oralarda bir
test etmek için de işte 5 günlüğüne
İspanya'ya gidecektim biletimi almıştım
tam o dönemde de benim gideceğim dönemde
de Şampiyonlar Ligi finali vardı
Inter Bayern Münih Santiago bar ne be o
Madrid ben akredi oldum yani başvuru
yaptım sonrasında cevap geldi
akreditasyonunuz onaylanmıştır Ama şöyle
bir şey var oefada finali hangi takımlar
oynuyor
Inter Baya yani İtalyanlar Almanlar
öncelik italyanlarda akreditasyon
önceliği ve Almanlar da Peki nerede
oynanıyor İspanya İspanyollar üçüncü
olarak da yani bir mucize ki zaten
hatalarını anladılar 3 gün sonra bir
mail daha
kusura bakmayın Bir yanlışlık olmuş
akreditasyonunuz iptal
ben tabii bittim o an bir şeyler yapmam
lazım Hemen cevap maili uçak biletlerimi
ekledim Otel rezervasyonumu ekledim Tam
turkishi saldırıyorum beni mağdur
ettiniz şöyle böyle sonrasında 3 gün
geçti 5 gün geçti cevap yok artık maça
bir hafta var bende İspanya'ya gideceğim
Umudumu Kestim Tabii tık mail geldi özür
dileriz akreditasyonumuz onaylı İyi
seyirler ya Bir Rüya Yani yine bir
kırılma anı şansımda hep yanımda şimdi
de hep yanımdadır Ya ben şanslı bir
insanımdır sonrasında gittim Şampiyonlar
Ligi finalini yerinde izledim olağanüstü
bir şey yani en büyük hayallerimden biri
Jose moorino'nun
bayernini Santiago barnio'da Çıplak
gözle izledim olağanüstü bir şey benim
artık radyoda misyonum yavaş yavaş
tamamlanmıştı ben kendim öyle
düşünüyordum beni bir şekilde
televizyona geçmem lazımdı bir şekilde
Benim kendime oralarda göstermem lazımdı
bir gün radyonun bir yemeği oldu
bizde de özel şendir gazeteci haber
programı yapıyor
oğlum dedi ya senin artık zamanın geldi
dedi Senin Televizyonda maç anlatman
lazım yayıncı kuruluşta abi dedim Benim
en büyük hayalim bu yayıncı kuruluşta
Süper Ligi bizim ligimizi anlatmak Ben
bununla yaşıyorum ama dedim hani nasıl
olacak Selamünaleyküm Ben geldim beni
alın mı diyeceğim Dedim yani hiçbir
bağlantım yok kimseyi tanımıyorum Tamam
adımı biraz duyurmaya başladım ama yok
dedi ben sana görüşme ayarlayacağım
Gerisi sende dedi tamam abi dedi Neyse
görüşmeyi ayarladı Ben cd'lerimle
gidiyorum maçlarımı kaydetmişim büyük
bir heyecanla dinlediler Tamam hafta
sonları gel dediler git gel git gel
Hiçbir şey yapmıyorum 5 gün radyoda
çalışıyorum 2 günde dışarıdan ortamı
gözlemliyorum Orada da bir Stajyerlik
yapıyoruz yani
staj dönemimiz hiç bitmiyor bir türlü
bitiremiyoruz
ardından Ben Askere gittim evlenmek için
kısa dönem asker 2 yıllık mezundum ama
açık öğretimden üçe dörde tamamladım
diplomamı aldım askerlik başvurusu
Askere gittim Mayısta döndüm Haziranda
evlendim davetiyemi götürdüğümde de
yayıncı kuruluşa artık Beni tanıyorlar
Ya 2 sene Orada dışarıdan maç anlatmışım
süperlik değil tabi işte İngiltere
Brezilya Rusya ne verirlerse dedim ben
artık işsizim haberiniz olsun
size de bunu söylemek istedim bir boşluk
varsa kadroda Hani ben buradayım tamam
Sen cv'ni yolla dediler yolladık Bir ay
geçti 2 ay geçti Ses yok Ne para kaldı
ne pul hiçbir şey yok risk alıp çıkmışım
radyodan misyonum tamamlandı diye askere
giderken Tazminatımı alıp çıkmışım
sonra bir telefon çaldı dedi Buyurun
Sizinle bir görüşme yapalım gittik
görüştük aradan iki hafta sonra bir
Ağustos 2014 iş başlangıcım kadrolu
şekilde yayıncı kuruluşta Tabii orada da
kendimi artık göstermem ıspat etmem
lazım Artık bekliyorum Bir Süper Lig
maçı gelsin de Kendimi göstereyim
Sonuçta başarının sırlarından biri de
açıkçası O fırsat geldiğinde şansı
kullanabilmek değerlendirebilmek o Süper
Lig maçı geldi ve ben o şansı
değerlendirdim
2014'te gelmemişti ama 2015 yılında ilk
Süper Lig maçımı anlattım ardından da bu
noktaya kadar geldim Şu anda derbi
spikeri olarak
adlandırılıyorum bu şekilde herkes beni
biliyor işte bir derbi varsa eğer Özkan
anlatır Özkan Öztürk anlatacaktır
diyorlar Çok büyük bir gurur hep
hayalini kurduğum şeyler Bunları
gerçekleştirdim 2017'de 2017 Aralık'ta
el klasik o anlattım yerinden Santiago
bernabe O da Barcelona Cristiano Ronaldo
Lionel Messi Çıplak gözle izleyip
anlattım 2021 Mayıs'ta Porto'da drago'da
Manchester City Chelsea Şampiyonlar Ligi
finalini Eğer olağanüstü bir şey yerinde
anlattım her gün şükrediyorum ve tabi
çocukken 90'ların sonu 2000'lerin başı
Ercan Taner izleyerek büyüdük biz benim
idolümdü örnek aldığım kişiydi Kahve
köşelerinde Ercan Taner'in anlattığı
maçları izliyordum ben ve o Ercan Taner
ile derbi anlattım yani pandemi
öncesiydi Fenerbahçe Galatasaray derbisi
kanal yönetimi şöyle bir karar aldı bu
derbiyi iki farklı spikere anlatacak bir
Özkan Öztürk diğeri Ercan Taner Daha ne
olsun bir insan için şimdi şöyle benden
mutlaka maç dinleyeniniz olmuştur Bu
maçları ben nasıl anlatıyorum Ne
yapıyorum
içimde açıkçası mesleğim icra ederken
bir volkan patlıyor benim zaman zaman
kendimi kaybediyorum sizlere de
göstermek istiyorum onu nasıl hangi
ortamda nasıl anlatıyorum bu maçları
isterseniz izleyelim sonrasında çok kısa
devam edeceğim
Galatasaray
taraftarının sevgilisi
ikizler sahnede
[Alkış]
lipa
bile Tüylerim diken diken oluyor Ben
çünkü yaşayarak işimi yapan bir kişiyim
biraz da kalabalıklar arasında Yalnızlık
olarak değerlendiriyorum yaptığım işi
tribünde binler ekranları başında
Milyonlar Ama sen orada tek başınasın
bir cümle ağzından çıkacak bir cümle
kariyerini bitirebilir ya da seni
zirveye taşıyabilir Hayat aslında Zaten
bir oyun ve biz tercihlerimizle
tutkumuzla arzumuzla isteğimizle kendi
yarattığımız şansımızla bu hayatta
rollerimizi seçiyoruz beni dinlediğiniz
için çok teşekkür ederim Sevgilerimi
sunuyorum